the boys are back in town and we've got
a lot to talk about in this easter egg
field episode that has a ton of call
backs of the comics
we're gonna be going through the entire
thing and breaking it all down
so if you want to know the ins and outs
as well as our theories then this is the
video for you
obviously there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you haven't had a chance to
check out the episode yet then i highly
recommend that you turn off now
anyway with that out of the way this is
the heavy spoilers show i'm your host
definition
now let's get into the boys okay so
episode 5 opens with the seven movie
this parody of batman v superman slash
the avengers
is swiftly becoming the backdrop of the
season and i love that we pretty much
see how vault presents the heroes of the
world
compared to how they actually are in the
comics homelander and co were able to
get away with so much
simply because vort's powerful pr team
always spun the story to be beneficial
to them
and here we see how maeve surveys the
wreckage before rescuing a character
called ruby
this scene is supposed to be the big
platform for maeve coming out
but it's pretty hammed up and doesn't
feel authentic at all
we see homelanders sat behind the camera
and it's likely that these lines were
forced in by the villain to show how
much control he
has over her life and the public's
perception of her
homelander mentions ajos rewrite and
that really stands out and further plays
up the notion of just how much
those behind the camera are actually
running the show joss whedon of course
took over justice league after zack
snyder left the project
sorry you shoved out and pretty much
changed the majority of the movie to
make it more in line with marvel
fans hated it but a mustache what they
didn't like about it
as i thought that i don't not like you
line was
was oscar worthy anyway it got to the
point that fans demanded that the
original version be released
and we're now getting the snyder cut on
hbo max
there's been a lot of what happened on
set brought to light recently by ray
fisher
who said it was a toxic work environment
and though not intentional when this
scene was being filmed
it hits home even harder now we also see
agent pierson played by greg grundberg
i think this is a play on agent phil
coulson from agents of shield
who of course starred in many of the
early marvel movies in addition to this
there's some cg mutants and green screen
suits
and i'd never really realized until now
but in pretty much
all of the avengers movies they don't
actually fight humans and instead they
fight either robots or aliens
again this shows the difference between
the marketing and the truth
as the seven pretty much go around
murdering people but i guess it's more
acceptable for people to watch someone
killing something they can't relate to
over something they can there's also the
girls get it done scene
which feels so forced and it reminded me
a lot of that bitten end game
you know the one the girls get it done
seen
it it absolutely kills me how they're
just riffing on that anyway
starlight also refers to herself as a
fembot which is pretty much just a robot
with a pretty face that is used as an
obstacle but has no real power or agency
this shows that since the introduction
of stormfront that she's been relegated
to second fiddle
and just feels like some set dressing
now we cut from one completely corporate
and manufactured image of how the heroes
are presented to the world
to a real one which was filmed on a
mobile phone in it we see homelander
arrive at a village in gutshot as super
terrorist
which accidentally hits an innocent
bystander in the process
i think this is a comment on police
brutality and in 2020 especially we've
been presented with several real-world
incidents
in which white authority figures arrived
in order to arrest someone
and they used excessive force these
moments are often filmed on mobile
phones
as is this scene and it shows the
juxtaposition between
a control camera moment and a real world
one homelander clearly could have taken
the villain in alive
as he wasn't phased by their powers but
instead he killed them
again showing excessive force homeland
his image really gets roomed by this
and the people demand retribution for
his actions as a war criminal
the pr team are offered up to help with
the situation but homelander takes
things into his own hands
and even ends up making an ally with
someone that i really wasn't expecting
him to
elsewhere is billy who after being
rejected by his wife last week
has decided that it's time to leave the
boys behind he really builds his
relationship with huey
and even calls him his canary at one
point which refers to a line by mother's
milk in episode 3.
the canary usage here is actually
referencing the saying canary in the
coal mine
canaries used to be taken down the mines
in order to indicate danger
as if there were invisible gases such as
carbon monoxide exposed to the miners
the canary would die quickly due to its
size and this would indicate danger
thus hughie is seen as someone that will
stop billy from rushing into things
due to his level-headedness in the
episode we learn that huey is very
similar to billy's brother lenny
who liked the character used to stop
butcher from running headfirst into
things
lenny 2 is mentioned in the comics and
the character sadly passed away which is
likely why billy gravitated towards huey
he catches mother's milk watching
outlander and begrudgingly the pair
track him down
now we actually see billy get a family
reunion with his auntie judy
and finally we see his dog terror
terror was a big aspect of the comics
that was
sadly emitted from the first season much
of the dismay of fans
he pretty much hums everything that he
can and i love that he has an
f pig there to keep him occupied in the
comics when butcher and huey first meet
hughie is upset about his girlfriend
dying and butcher actually wants to make
him laugh and says effete
which not only says to huey that it's
just one of them things but it also
makes terror run off and start humping
another dog
which is one of the funniest parts of
the first volume
shout outs to piss from we we felt i
mean chris from
3c films for hitting me up with that one
you're my canary
another scene that pulls directly from
the comics is the one featuring kimiko
the scene in which he confronts three
men before beating the crap out of them
and ripping off one of their faces is
line for line
exactly the same as how it plays out in
the first volume
yes even down to the bit about kittens
this scene was actually used to
introduce kimiko in the comics
and it pretty much cemented her as a
complete badass
here it's also dropped a great effect
and lets hardcore fans know that the
show is still pulling from the source
material
even if it doesn't always seem like it i
loved how this trio also talked about
the whitewashing in hollywood
and as we've seen from the set of the
seven the studio is pushing this
idea of the white superman whilst in
real life minorities are oppressed by
the corporation
a train as we know has been ousted by
the group and at the moment
there's no people of color in it well
except for black noir
who doesn't really identify with a race
so that there's everything covered there
now another interesting thing that i
noticed in this episode
is the vietnamese crepe truck which we
learn is on the set of the seven
either people eating from this or
discussing it pops up three times in the
episode and now it might be a reach i
think it could tie in with the fresca
that was dropped quite heavily in the
first three episodes
potentially both vort and the church
could be drugging the food
in order to keep the seven submissive
and the constant repetition of this food
and drink
has clearly been picked for a reason
we've seen not only the deep fallen line
but also a train who goes from refusing
to say any of the lines written for his
character
to dropping them in his final scene for
the film though he is blackmailed i
think the repetition
of the truck could mean something or
absolutely nothing but you know how he
like a reach now speaking of the deep
we learn that his wedding to cassandra
was fast-tracked and he's now doing the
chat show circuit in order to rebuild
his public image
he appears with katie couric speaking on
behalf of the church of the collective
and i got a lot of tom cruise
scientology vibes here down to the
lighting
and the interview style which the show
is clearly riffing on
the church will definitely come back up
as stormfront even mentions that she
used to be a member
she hints that she left after they
started letting in more demographics
which again teases at the character
being linked to her comic book
counterpart
now just as billy goes to leave his
auntie someone ups the ante
and that is black noir who we learn has
tailed butcher from becker's
terrible now the boys buy some time by
reporting a gas leak
so they can do a home alone and set up
some traps
huey and butcher have a really heavy
scene together and i love how mother's
milk is the glue that's sort of stopping
everything from falling apart
though billy initially seems like he's
lashing out he's clearly trying to keep
huey safe
which hammers home this surrogate
brother relationship
belly's real brother of course died and
i believe that he's only trying to
protect huey
even though he goes about it the wrong
way annie's mother also pops up
and tries to repair the relationship
with her daughter stormfront talks her
around to entertaining her
and we also learned some of the
backstory about the character
namely that a mother's name was adele
now we have been theorizing that
stormfront was actually created during
the second world war
after vault was given permission to
experiment on jewish people
we actually see stormfront's mother
during this episode and due to the age
difference between the two
it does seem like she could have been
around during this time in the comics we
discovered that the majority of the
seven
were created when pregnant women were
injected with copious amounts of
compound b homelander doesn't even know
his mother
but the fact that stormfront does hints
at her being alive before vault
really came to power and started doing
this procedure routinely
she doesn't look old enough to have been
a teen during the 40s
but this is a photo so again it could be
taken at any time really
also we know that vault create pr images
for the seven
so this might not even be her mother as
we know that she was already a
completely different hero in the 70s
again might be reaching might not you
know you know we're like a reach though
however there is one interesting theory
that the show seems to be confirming
and at one point we see stormfront on
the phone to lamplighter
last week we said we think stormfront is
slowly ousting the seven
so she can bring the old team back so
far we've had eddie the eagle pop up
soldier boy has been name-dropped and
now lamplighter has stopped by two
it seems like the pieces are slowly
falling into place and the introduction
of sean ashmore brings a lot with it
lamplighter is of course an old member
of the group and the character possesses
the ability of pyrokinesis
this is kind of ironic as in the x-men
ashmore played iceman
and here he's doing the opposite
becoming a character more in line with
pyro
either way there's a lot to look forward
to and i can't wait to see if more from
the oldest seven pop
up now a marketing team pitched the idea
of maeve's new image
in which he will go as the name brave
mave
i don't know how they don't kill
themselves laughing when they come up
with this stuff
now the company want to seem like
they're accepting of the lgbt community
but they force her to say that she's a
lesbian instead of just being bisexual
her girlfriend elena is told that she
has to play up being more masculine in
order to not offend the public
too much as it may be problematic they
don't see how problematic their forcing
of this image is
and they continue to be worse and worse
elena walks out
and mae realizes that enough is enough
and that she has to take homeland down
this is a big turn up for the books i
can see her at the deep in a train
potentially even joining the boys in
order to bring an end to homelander
kimiko is also working freelance and
completing missions
her contact is actually the woman friend
she went to last week
and clearly she used the information he
gave her
in order to hire her friend she tries to
talk her out of going down this dark
path
but she's just filled with so much rage
that it's impossible too
she's almost as bad as the soup she
hates and her arc
acts in real shades of grey throughout
this episode a train leaves the seven
officially
and i thought it was hilarious that he
did his final monologue
to a body double we jump to protests
outside vort
and see victoria newman delivering a
speech
in the comics the character is actually
a man known as victor k
newman and they are a soup that goes
under the name vic the beep
bick runs for vice president and after
his running mate gets elected
he kills them so that he can take his
spot in the oval office
i'm not sure whether this will be the
case in the show but they've clearly
given her this name for an important
reason
and it's just something to bear in mind
homelanders swoops down and tries to win
the crowd round
but they refuse to buy into the
pandering now i actually got to see this
episode
early and it's been killing me for two
weeks with the comment section on my
video
telling me that homelander goes wild and
massacres the crowd
unfortunately it's just a fake out and
homelander
just imagines what he would do to them
are you disappointed
let me know in the comments below now
what is interesting though is that we're
starting to see homelanders armor get
chipped away
though he has the same powers as
superman he doesn't really have a
weakness per se
and is pretty much unstoppable however
when discussing this
anthony starr who plays the character
stated that homeland's weakness
is actually his ego he's the most
powerful man
on the planet and because of this the
perception that he has of himself is so
fragile
that it's completely easy to dismantle
it after the crowd shouted down he just
goes into autopilot
and resorts to the catchphrase you guys
are the real heroes
and i loved seeing that this was so
stressful for ashley that some of her
hair fell out
now to raise the stakes even more the
fire service finished their gastic
investigation
and thus noir can move in on butcher i
absolutely love this scene
and it's laced with a lot of horror
elements such as the slow moving
footsteps of the character
as he walks about the house i've got a
lot of michael myers vibes from this
scene
and similar to the shape this creature
is devoid of personality
and seemingly invincible he is however
clearly bought slapdog
and much like his role in the comics he
operates without question
and is just edgar's puppet i believe
this is why edgar isn't scared of
homelander
as he knows that he has black noir under
his control and can take him out if
needs be
butcher manages to get edgar to call him
off by blackmailing him with photographs
of homelander in his son ryan
which he threatens he'll release if
anyone is killed
it's a really tense scene that shows the
boys do have their way to defeat the
supes
they just have to be cunning about it
billy says farewell to tara as the
police arrive
and he promises to get becca back
showing that he's finally had a big
change of heart
he gives tara an f toy and what a way
for him to say his goodbyes
now we jump to starlight at the crepe
truck and she sneaks into stormfront's
trailer
she hacks her laptop with the password
adele which was the name of her mother
and in it she finds emails from the
psychiatric hospital that lamplighter
was at
she's unable to read them as stormfront
enters the trailer but clearly the bear
have been sending messages back and
forth
and he tries to shout her down but
stormfront reveals that she knows annie
was the one that leaked compound b
however annie collapsed back revealing
that she knows the truth about liberty
and stormfront downplays being
prejudiced but we know the truth
stonefront says she'll be a big help to
her and clearly she's gonna be using her
at some point in the future though
we don't know what just yet just as
things are about to go down
homelander knocks on the trailer and
goes to stormfront for help
probably the weirdest sex scene i've
ever come across not my proudest one uh
sorry not my proudest
scene i've ever had to break down and i
don't know what it is with this guy but
but he just keeps getting weirder and
weirder now this is obviously
all part of stormfront's play and she's
clearly setting up certain heroes
against one another
whilst putting other things in place i
believe that she's gonna start
blackmailing homelander
in order to not only supplant him with a
group but also banish him to obscurity
this is the same punishment that was
dealt to her and she likely wants
revenge for the way that broadcasts are
out
she also wants a boob slated biebs now
though this is weird what it does show
is that stormfront is pretty much
invincible
and he's gonna be difficult to take down
when it comes down to it
anyway that closes out the episode and
as always yeah i'd love to hear your
thoughts on it
so comment below and let me know if you
enjoyed this video then please drop a
thumbs up
and make sure you check out our
breakdown of homelander which is going
to be linked at the end
we go over the character's full bio from
the comics so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more
don't forget we're also giving away a
free copy of the christopher nolan
collection to one random subscriber
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video drop
a thumbs up
and also subscribe to the channel please
now if you want to support the channel
and get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat is on the discord
server linked in the description or
heavy spoilers on twitter
thanks for making it until the end of
the video you've been the best
i'm in definition i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]
you